[Music]
it is our primary objective in this
motion picture to alert surgeons to the
danger of post-operative velopharyngeal
incompetence
in tna surgery a lasting hypernasality
following adenoidectomy
is not an uncommon complication it has
been reported to occur
in one of every 100 tna operations with
a temporary hypernasality
in 7.2 percent
thus it becomes obvious that
velopharyngeal function should be taken
into consideration
[Music]
pre-operatively
historically the concept of motion
picture x-rays was presented in 1897
two years following von renken's
discovery of x-ray
it was reported that the use of x-ray
would be important to document speech
as we view the normal phonation pattern
it is of interest to note that
cinephorography presents the dynamic
aspects of function
in contrast to the classical static
x-ray the lateral skull film does not
provide the functional aspects of head
and neck anatomy
cinerography allows us to view
swallowing
respiration and speech patterns normal
head and neck anatomy
as it relates to speech has been
thoroughly documented
the anatomical relationships during the
phonation of the vowel
ah demonstrate the following anatomy
14 anatomical components are considered
essential
in the routine radiological and physical
examination
of a pre-operative t and a patient
number one
adenoidal area this lymphoid tissue will
vary greatly in mass as we will see
the area is critical during phonation in
children with slight velopharyngeal
incompetencies
number two the tonsils
number three velum the size shape
and placement of the velum is also
critical in normal phonation
the velum is in this position during the
phonation of the vowel
ah the constrictor muscles of the
pharynx number four
move in conjunction with the velum and
other pharyngeal musculature
to accomplish phonation and dilution
note the position of the arch of the
atlas number five
during phonation of vowels and the
majority of consonants the velum will
elevate to the level of or slightly
superior to the arch of the atlas
number six the tongue number seven the
hard palate
at the posterior aspect of the hard
palate is number eight the posterior
nasal spine
the absence of the spine is of
considerable clinical significance
nine indicates the position of the other
cervical vertebrae
number two the tonsil is located between
10 the palatal glasses muscle
and 11 the palatopharyngeus
the eustachian tube is number 12 number
13
the tensor palatal muscle and 14 levator
palatal muscle
tense and elevate the velum during
deglution and phonation
normal velopharyngeal function should
serve as a basis for the
pre-adenotonsillectomy evaluation
deglution has three phases oral
bolus organization movement of the bolus
from the anterior position in the mouth
into the pharynx
during this stage the velum is elevated
and contacts the superior constrictor
muscle
or posterior pharyngeal wall while the
tongue
compresses the bolus against the velum
the velum's purpose is to seal off the
nasopharynx
and to prevent any portion of the bolus
from being regurgitated
into the nasopharynx the third
the esophageal phase the bolus moves
into
and down the esophagus normal phonation
as demonstrated by this 18 year old
post-operative
a patient the velum contacts and seals
the nasopharynx from nasal air escapage
on all vowels and all consonants
except the three nasal consonants m n
and ng
the phonation of ah demonstrates one of
the best positions to view the essential
anatomical components
soft palate superior constrictor arch of
the atlas
and the tongue
[Applause]
when considering adenotonsillectomy the
surgeon should examine the oral and
pharyngeal areas closely
noting bluish coloration in the mucosa
of the median raphae
the presence of a bifid uvula and the
size and shape of the velum
he should palpate the pellet to
establish the presence of a posterior
nasal spine the history should note
feeding problems during infancy
especially incidents of nasal
regurgitation
slow or delayed speech development and
whether the pre-operative speech quality
is hypo
or hyper nasal when one or more of these
findings are confronted
one should be alert to the possibility
of a congenital velopharyngeal
incompetence
sub-mucus cleft palate or other
anomalies
a radiological examination to include
cineflorographic studies during
deglution and phonation in pre-operative
evaluation of suspicious cases
will serve to avoid a speech disaster
and
medical legal challenge
three types of patients will be compared
post operative
tna incompetence cleft palate
incompetence
and sub mucous cleft palate incompetence
a tna was performed at the age of three
the patient is now nine deglution is
considered adequate
however during phonation note the large
velopharyngeal incompetence
no posterior nasal spine was evident
note the velopharyngeal incompetence
during phonation
positions of the soft palate superior
constrictor
arch of the atlas and the tongue are
indicated
this 11 year old had a tna at the age of
seven
the deglution pattern is normal the
velum is mobile
it elevates but does not flex during
phonation resulting
in a velopharyngeal incompetence the tna
was considered indicated
due to frequent respiratory infections
the third case a 14 year old had a t and
a
at age 11. hypernasality resulted
note the large velum the position of the
tongue and superior constrictor
a posterior nasal spine was present
only occasionally the velum contacts the
superior constrictor
on isolated vowels the high concavity of
the sphenoid vault
is the result of the adenoidectomy
this 12 year old cleft palate patient
had a tna performed at age nine
continuous nasal speech was noted
visually
compare these patients born with palatal
defects
with the previous group who
pre-operatively presented no palatal or
facial anomalies
the classical cleft palate deglution
pattern is illustrated
during the pharyngeal stage the
posterior base of the tongue is
depressed to allow the bolus flow
into the esophagus because the residual
velum is not adequate to seal the
nasopharynx
this compensatory deglution pattern is
established early in life
to prevent continuous nasal
regurgitation
during phonation the velopharyngeal
incompetence is extreme
the open vowel position demonstrates the
insufficient anatomical relationships
noted between the tongue
soft palate arch of the atlas and
pharyngeal constrictors
this 11 year old medial repair of a
cleft palate
had a t and a performed at 10 and
demonstrates minimum veto pharyngeal
incompetence
the tna was performed due to continuous
upper respiratory infections
note minimum incompetence during
phonation the loss of the adenoidal
tissue
increase the incompetency and
hypernasality
normal deglution is demonstrated by this
11 year old cleft palate patient
however palatal incompetence is seen
during phonation
note the high sphenoid vault in the
nasopharynx and the relationships of
velum to the pharyngeal constrictors
arch of the atlas and tongue each of the
last group of patients
pre-operatively indicated no hypernasal
speech patterns
the initial patient 12 years of age had
a t and a at age five
he has no posterior nasal spine and soon
after the tna was performed
hypernasal speech resulted note the
minimum velopharyngeal incompetence
another post-operative tna with minimum
velopharyngeal incompetence
again note the relationship of the velum
to the pharyngeal constrictors
arch of the atlas and tongue
patient nine years of age had a tna at
seven
resulting in marked hypernasality he
presented classical submucous symptoms
of compensatory deglutition pattern
no posterior nasal spine and a bifid
uvula
note the small size of the velum and the
lack of contact between the velum and
pharyngeal constrictors
this film has presented cineflorography
as one modality and examination criteria
for pre-adenotonsillectomy evaluations
when velopharyngeal function is abnormal
adenotonsillectomy should be carefully
considered the surgeon must be on guard
against a potential speech complication
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you